people like to believe in fairy tales  but of course are you I believe that the  characters we read about on the page end  up being more real than the men you  stand beside us  Pam sake Jackie Jackie check let me  check people need their history they  need to know that real men actually  lived here  but I've grown accustomed to a great  divide between what people believe in  what I know to be raised how would you  like him remember there should be more  horses more soldier are you doing this  mrs. Kennedy's more crying what cameras  this is my finished look like our bear  it's not smooth you don't have to do it  I will  that's Jack somewhere what was real boys  I'm guessing you won't allow me to write  any of that now because I never said  that to December before you drift to  sleep upon your [ __ ]  think back on all